- By some measures, our
economy is doing great.
- Food, fuel, everything costs too much.
- [Narrator] Both of these
candidates are kind of right.
Leading into the midterm
elections inflation is high,
the highest in the last 40 years
and gas prices are volatile,
though they've come down recently,
there's still a lot of uncertainty
about where they're going next.
But then again, there's
incredibly low unemployment,
just look at the number
of job openings right now.
Things are expensive,
but people are working.
Yet most economists polled
by the Wall Street Journal
believe the US is headed
towards a recession
in the next year.
- The economy is always a
big deal in any election.
I mean, as James Carville once famously
coined the term in 1992.
- It's the economy stupid.
- This year is obviously a year
where we're seeing a lot of interest,
a lot of intensity and
debate about the economy.
- [Narrator] Here's how the
economy actually is doing
and why it matters for
the November midterms.
- I can't tell you how many
times I've seen gas pumps
and grocery store aisles
in political ads this year.
- [Narrator] Inflation is one
of the big economic measures
you can feel personally.
- And I feel the pain too because
I do the grocery shopping.
- [Narrator] And not just
at the grocery store,
although the price of food has gone up
more than most things.
If you look at median weekly earnings
people are making less than they were
during the last election,
if adjusted for inflation.
- Inflation is sort of
taking a bite out of,
you know, what otherwise
would be a fairly strong
and robust economy coming
out of the pandemic.
- [Narrator] Republicans
are largely blaming.
- [Reporter 1] Man's reckless spending.
- [Reporter 2] Trillions in spending.
- Out of control spending.
- [Narrator] While Democrats point out.
- The supply chain.
- More microchips here in America
to get the supply chain moving again.
- We'll beat inflation one chip at a time.
- There's a lot of reasons for why
inflation is at this super high level.
You know, it has to do
with global supply chains,
it has to do with the pandemic,
it has to do with energy prices.
You know, the situation in Ukraine,
all of that has contributed to
astronomical price increases
and so both parties are trying to point
to certain aspects of that bigger formula.
- [Narrator] Another place voters
have felt the economic pressure.
- If you're fed up every time you fill up.
- [Narrator] Let's take a closer look
at that gas price chart.
Here is where the Russian
invasion of Ukraine began.
Experts largely blamed that
war for the initial increase
but it stayed high for
a number of reasons.
Republicans blame.
- [Reporter 3] Our energy
production has been crippled.
- They've cratered our
domestic energy production.
- [Narrator] While Democrats blame.
- [Reporter 4] Oil companies
gouging us at the pump.
- [Reporter 5] Price gouging by big oil.
- Both sides have some points
but there's no sort of easy answer.
- [Narrator] Analysts pointed things
beyond the Biden administration's control,
like maintenance at refineries.
- Some of these things
just have to do with,
you know, global supply chains.
Coming out of the pandemic,
we're just obviously in a really
weird time for the economy.
- [Narrator] Americans'
frustration over rising prices
show up in arguably the
most important factor
going into the election, how people feel.
This is the Consumer Sentiment Index,
it measures how optimistic or pessimistic
people are feeling about the economy.
In the last 40 years, every
time the President's party
has lost a large number
of seats in the midterms,
it was after a period where Americans felt
pessimistic about the economy.
- You never want voters
to be in a grumpy mood
when you're the party in power.
It's easier for them to sort of cast
that ballot in opposition.
- [Narrator] And right
now people feel worse
about the economy than they even did
during the Great Recession.
Even though there are far fewer people
filing unemployment claims today
than there were during that recession.
There are also more jobs being added today
than even during the Great
Recession's recovery.
By these measures, the economy is good,
but where people feel
the economy the most,
the grocery store and the
gas station, it's not.
- For voters, they're definitely hearing,
you know, the blame game from both sides
and ultimately for them,
it's gonna come down,
which party do you think has
the best chance of fixing it?
(upbeat music)